We would like to invite everyone to the Paradox Live that will be held this time.The
true identity is the club that has truly revived.
Paradox's music is
meaningless just because it's a chance to acknowledge who we are now.If we're
going to do it, we have to aim to be number one.
If you want to protect this store,
go to the stage. If you
win, you can get rid of this crap.
Let's just take the top and make 10 billion. Riggan and his brothers bought it in a box and smeared the names of the red guys on their hands.  That's what I
promised.
We may be silent or geniuses,
but
this is the story of those who control the shadows.
[Music]
Hop's hip-hop is an anti-song. I can't stand being robbed.
We're connected through music.
That's mine, I won't lose to anyone, I wo
n't lose, I'll make it clear to you